this video is sponsored by Squarespace
the best way to make an amazing website
we've had the two thousand twenty
sixteen inch macbook pro in the office
for just over a week now and even though
there's only one single change at least
on the surface i did find something else
that i mentioned a bit i have to say
that i am so impressed that i'm
considering selling my fifteen thousand
dollar Mac Pro and just using this
MacBook Pro with the new 5600 M graphics
card I know some of you need great
performance but at the same time you
would like to have the portability and
you want to know how much performance
aren't you really losing if you go with
the MacBook Pro and that's exactly what
we're going to talk about today now the
Mac Pro is definitely more powerful mine
has 192 gigabytes of RAM a 12 core Xeon
processor and the super powerful Vega 2
GPU with 32 gigabytes of ultra-fast HBM
to memory now on top of that I also have
the afterburner card installed which
accelerates pro res and pro res rah and
this thing alone costs $2,000 but I'll
talk about why many of you probably
won't need it with this new MacBook Pro
the spec of my macbook pro cost four
thousand and ninety nine dollars but
realistically you could buy the base
eight core model which has pretty much
the same real-world performance to make
it a flat four thousand dollars it has
the 2.4 gigahertz a core a nine
processor the brand-new AMD radeon 5600
M and 32 gigabytes of ram which yes I
know is a lot less than the hundred
ninety two gigs and iMac but more on
this in just a bit as well
I'm gonna get into the performance
numbers but first I want to point out
the benefits of buying each one of these
Macs
I also point out that this premium Mac's
tech hoody is super soft its stylish and
you could check out yourself and support
the channel at the same time using the
merch shelf down below now with the new
MacBook Pro you can get work done
anywhere and unlike most Windows laptops
you don't have to be plugged in since
the performance is exactly the same when
you're unplugged adding on to this you
can now get a fairly inexpensive battery
pack that will power your MacBook Pro
through USB type-c and even charge it up
while you're on the go doing serious
work and at least double your battery
life which is awesome now the Mac Pro on
the other hand is a different beast
completely you definitely don't get the
same bang for the buck
the
model is so slow for the money that this
MacBook Pro the cost $2,000 less is
actually faster in every single way in
order to get more value you have to
spend more but it's a commercial-grade
computer that gives you top-notch
reliability for computational tasks and
performance at least on the high end
that you simply can't get in any other
Mac along with that everything from the
RAM to graphics and storage and even the
processor is upgradable so we actually
saved about $2,000 by upgrading the RAM
ourselves instead of buying it and
that's just the hundred ninety two
gigabytes instead of the maximum one
point five terabytes now specs do matter
but they don't tell the whole story what
really matters is real-world performance
and I've been using this Mac Pro as my
main rig for over six months now so I
have some real-world observations and
comparisons that I have to get out there
before we get into that performance I
want to give a shout-out to our sponsor
Squarespace if you've been thinking
about making your own website now is the
perfect time and Squarespace is
seriously the best way to go you could
build a great looking website like we
did with literally no web making
experience it doesn't matter if you want
a portfolio a blog ecommerce or anything
else
you just choose a template and customize
blocks of text and images it's
incredibly simple it's affordable and
ours have been running flawlessly for
many years now bringing in new clients
thanks to its built-in SEO tools which
means that your website will actually be
found online start your free two week
trial with no credit card needed by
going to squarespace.com slash max set
or by using our custom link below and
when you're ready to launch save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or a
domain starting off with processor
performance using Geekbench 5 the Mac
Pro's processor is way faster it only
has four more cores but a lot of this is
because it's not thermally limited like
the thin macbook pro now running
Cinebench r20 which pushes all of the
course to their limits like when you're
transporting footage or cpu rendering
the mac pro is once again much faster on
top of that the mac pro stays cool and
completely silent instead of ramping up
and having loud fans now moving on to
graphics performance with Geekbench 5's
metal test once again the Mac Pro is
faster in fact it is more than twice as
fast but I want to point out
but the new AMD 5600 I'm graphics card
is much faster than the previous one so
the difference is smaller than before
taking a closer look at this graphics
card if you're just judging by the name
5600 M doesn't sound much faster than
the 5500 M but when it actually comes to
performance we have 40 cores instead of
24 and now it's using HP m2 memory just
like my Mac Pro which is more than twice
as fast
so overall the Mac Pro has up to 200%
more performance and has way more RAM
but does that actually stack up the same
in real-world use to start off I know
these machines aren't made for gaming
but I want to throw it in running
Unigine heaven the Mac Pro is 50% faster
which is a good improvement but not as
much as we would expect I also want to
point out that this new MacBook Pro with
the 5600 M is actually faster for gaming
then the best graphics card in the 5k
iMac and the $5,000 iMac Pro which is
crazy now if you're doing graphics
rendering I compared both using blender
benchmark and the Mac Pro took 16
minutes compared to 22 minutes with a
macbook another big difference but not
the two times difference that I expected
judging off of the metal test now before
we test photo editing and Lightroom
classic let's get into video editing
with Final Cut Pro the Mac Pro finished
the graphics heavy Bruce X benchmark in
just 6 seconds which is crazy fast but
the new MacBook Pro took just 9 seconds
which really surprised me the previous
best 16 inch mac pro pro takes 13
seconds which was already a big
improvement from before but now this
2020 model is actually closer to the Mac
Pro than the previous model testing 4k
stabilization the Mac Pro took just 4
seconds to stabilize a 20-second clip
but the MacBook Pro was just as fast now
that seems absolutely crazy and the only
way that I could explain it is that
there are other factors that are
limiting it and we're no longer being
slowed down by the graphics card moving
on to exporting a five-minute 4k project
with many effects using h.264 footage
which is the format that most youtubers
use the macro Pro does take longer than
the macro but only by 32 seconds
this means that if you had a 20-minute
project that would only be a
minute difference in as far as the
actual editing experience and smoothness
I could not tell a difference running a
similar test but using 8-bit h.265
footage or HEV see the export speed is
actually identical since they're both
using the same exact t2 chip and the
graphics cards aren't the limitations
even with multiple Lutz and color
Corrections and film grain applied so
this is just saying a lot for the
MacBook Pro now I do want to add in that
if you are stacking an insane amount of
effects here just putting a bunch of
stuff on there the Mac Pro will pull out
ahead but even for my toughest projects
it is really hard to tell the difference
moving on to much heavier stuff like raw
editing working with crazy aka red raw
footage the Mac Pro is faster but not by
as much as I expected this is because
Final Cut is actually limited by the CPU
if we take a look at a program like
DaVinci Resolve the Mac Pro has a bigger
lead here and the same thing goes for
c200 raw footage but I want to say that
playing back this codec results in the
same perfect performance even at 4k 60
with a lot and other effects applied and
in the past this was never possible on a
MacBook Pro but now it is with this new
much powerful much more powerful
graphics card that is because software
is now getting more efficient and things
are being moved to the graphics which
really helps because this Mac Pro has
that 5600 M and people that may have
needed a 10 to $15,000 Mac Pro six
months ago may not need one anymore to
prove this point I even play back some
EK pro res roth footage on a a k
timeline with effects and it played back
almost perfectly on this macbook pro
without that $2000 afterburner card
which shocked me now the Mac Pro can
actually do three streams of this 8k but
personally I have no need for that and I
think that most people don't either in
seeing how you can play back aka probe
Ezreal which is about 40% harder than
pro res that just really says a lot now
on to photo editing I literally could
not tell a difference when actually
editing the macro Pro is as smooth as
butter just like the Mac Pro and even
though on paper you would think that
there would be a big difference there
really isn't and
this is using 42 megapixel RAW images
where most people edit 24 megapixel or
lower basically we're at a point that
this eight core 5600 our MacBook is so
fast and the software is finally better
optimized with the latest versions that
you really don't need any better specs
to get amazing performance now when we
exported 500 rah 42 megapixel edited
images we did see a difference in
performance the mac pro was about twice
as fast if you don't care about that
speed the performance of editing is
basically the same I said that I would
talk about the huge difference in RAM so
here it is I honestly didn't notice a
difference between the machines in the
last few versions of Mac OS RAM usage is
just getting more and more efficient and
even with 192 gigabytes of RAM to my Mac
Pro I have never seen it use more than
72 gigs
that's the most I've ever seen it
usually is between 40 to 60 gigs now if
you know that you're gonna have multiple
big programs open like After Effects and
Premiere Pro and bunch of chrome tabs
you might want to go for the 64 gig
option in the MacBook Pro for 400 bucks
more but from what I could tell and
monitoring my usage even you having
large couple our projects and final cuts
the sweet spot is 32 gigabytes of RAM
that's because Mac OS can compress what
you're doing and save it to the
ultra-fast SSDs and pull from there so
the actual experience even though 32
gigs of ram is really good now another
thing I noticed is that the 2020 MacBook
Pro seems to run a little bit cooler
which results in slightly higher CPU
scores than last year with the same
exact processor which is a nice surprise
overall now that software is even more
efficient and we have faster graphics in
the MacBook even less people need a Mac
Pro and that means you could save money
and be mobile at the same time now I
still have to decide if I'm gonna sell
my Mac Pro or not but I know that if I
didn't already own one and if it was
there on my desk I definitely would be
buying the MacBook Pro over the Mac Pro
saving a bunch of money and being able
to edit wherever I want to let me know
your thoughts down in the comment
section below and if you want to score a
great deal in MacBook Pro we're gonna
have some links in the video description
once again check out our merch you guys
can
channel and get an awesome design like
this if you need a website check out
Squarespace they are awesome
click above to subscribe and we will see
you in the next video
[Music]